If you want to know the truth if Hoffman could
have survived at the end of the Saw movies...
then stick around to the end of this video.
Throughout Jigsaw’s active years, he brought
on a few disciples to help him carry out his
plans, and eventually take over for him after
his passing.
One of these students would go on to overshadow
John Kramer himself, and that was Lieutenant
Detective Mark Hoffman.
Welcome to Horror History, my name is Admiral
Chancellor Professor CZsWorld, and in today’s
lesson we’re going over the entire known
history of the most evil man to bear the Jigsaw
name so far, Mark Hoffman.
Hoffman may have been partially named after
a well-known American criminal, Mark William
Hoffmann, who similarly spun into a murderous
episode after his plans unravel.
His name was also a tribute to the late Gregg
Hoffman, one of the trio of producers responsible
for Saw 1 and 2, who is still honored in the
credits of every movie.
The Saw character Hoffman did not start as
a psychopath though, he never even had a criminal
record during his lifetime, so to understand
his journey, let’s go back to his earliest
mention in the series.
Hoffman was likely born in the mid 60s.
In 1976, his sister Angelina was born.
It is not known what happened to his parents,
but in his adulthood, Angelina was his only
family member.
“I know she was your only family.”
After graduating from Renfield University,
Mark Hoffman became a cop in the early 80s.
“I’ve been a cop for 20 years. Is that long enough for you?”
One of his earliest known cases took place
at an elementary school, where he and Officer
Daniel Rigg investigated an abusive teacher.
They are unable to get solid evidence against
the guy, and a frustrated Rigg overreacts
to a slap on the back and punches the teacher
in the face.
"IN THE FACE!!"
Hoffman claims that the teacher attacked Rigg
first, which is a long stretch of the truth,
and signs an affidavit vowing that he witnessed
it.
I see this as the first example of Hoffman’s
belief that it is OK to sidestep required
procedures to bring someone to justice, or
at least what he views as justice.
In this case, he believes the teacher is guilty,
and he bends the truth in order to see that
he is locked up.
He would later use a similar tactic to try
to bring another criminal to justice, but
this time, it would be personal.
In 1997, Hoffman’s sister, Angelina, was
killed during a domestic dispute with her
boyfriend, Seth Baxter.
She was just 25 years old.
Mark felt helpless after losing his only family.
His job was to serve and protect, but he was
unable to protect the only person that mattered
to him.
He became an alcoholic and lost all joy in
his life.
This gets the attention of John Kramer, whose
goal is to make sure everyone cherishes their
lives.
“You sit in bars until closing.
You drink so you can sleep.
You stagger to your car and then you start
in all over again the next day.”
But John doesn’t take action on Hoffman
quite yet.
After a long trial, Baxter is eventually convicted
and sentenced to 25 years in prison starting
in 1999.
In the meantime, there is another police incident
that tells us more about Hoffman’s character.
While responding to a distress call at a flophouse
full of junkies, he saves the life of another
officer named Matt Gibson.
After ordering the junkie to drop the weapon,
Hoffman proceeds to shoot him several times.
Like the incident at the school, Hoffman is
taking the law into his own hands rather than
letting due process play out.
He also sees this as a favor to Gibson…
“You owe me.”
...but Gibson, one of the few cops who is
not corrupt, reports him for brutality.
“What brutality?”
However, he still saved an Officer’s life,
so Hoffman ends up getting promoted.
One year later, Gibson transferred to Internal
Affairs, where he busted three of Hoffman’s
men, and Hoffman swore he’d have his revenge.
Just remember that, because it could come
back.
I’m not saying it’s gonna come back……..
But it might come back.
But for now, let’s fast forward a couple
more years to May of 2004.
Seth Baxter had served 5 years for the murder
of Hoffman’s sister, at which point he was
released on a technicality.
Seems to happen a lot in this city.
At this point, the police department had recently
formed a serial killer task force responsible
for solving a series of murders all accredited
to a criminal who was beginning to become
known as the Jigsaw killer.
Hoffman was not an investigator on the first
couple cases, but is aware of Jigsaw’s activity,
which gives him an idea of how he could get
revenge on Seth Baxter.
That June, he creates a trap similar in style
to the traps that Jigsaw had used to kill
his victims, but with one key difference.
Hoffman’s trap, which involved a giant swinging
pendulum, was inescapable.
Hoffman took pleasure in watching his sister’s
killer get torn in half through a peephole
in the wall, but little did he know, Jigsaw
was still keeping an eye on him, and knew
about his copycat crime.
Jigsaw waited in the elevator at Hoffman’s
apartment complex to sedate him and drag him
to his workshop.
When he awakes, he finds himself in a real
Jigsaw trap, where his arms are tied to a
chair and wired to a shotgun, so that too
much movement would pull the trigger.
John explains that he believes everyone deserves
a second chance, and that in his games, if
the player survives, they are instantly rehabilitated.
John did not appreciate Hoffman ripping off
his work, because Hoffman’s game did not
offer the victim a chance to survive.
But true to his word, John is going to give
Hoffman a chance.
He lets him out of the chair, and tells him
that he can try to arrest or kill him, but
if he does so, the truth about Hoffman’s
guilt will automatically be released.
So Hoffman is given no choice but to join
Jigsaw in his work to test and rehabilitate
others who no longer cherished their lives.
By joining him, Hoffman had passed Jigsaw’s
first test, and would begin learning his moral
code and methods of rehabilitation.
During the construction of the next Jigsaw
trap, John would impart one of the most important
rules onto his pupil.
The first victim that Hoffman assisted Jigsaw
in capturing was a man named Paul whose will
to live would be tested in a maze of barbed
wires.
During the setup of this trap, Jigsaw explains
one of the most important rules of the operation.
Roll it.
“The heart cannot be involved.
Emotionally, there can be nothing there.
It can never be personal.”
Which seems kind of hypocritical because almost
everyone John tested was connected to him
personally… but maybe this is a rule just
for Hoffman, because he already went after
his sister’s ex-boyfriend with the pendulum
trap, and Jigsaw feared he would use the platform
for personal reasons again.
Using his inside knowledge as a metropolitan
police detective, Hoffman warns John that
there is a cop who is onto him, a man by the
name of David Tapp.
John plans to throw Tapp off by having Hoffman
plant Dr. Lawrence Gordon’s penlight at
one of the crime scenes.
He does this at the site of the next trap,
where a victim is burned alive trying to solve
Jigsaw and Hoffman’s puzzle.
As far as we know, Hoffman was not involved
in the other traps that took place in 2004,
because Jigsaw wanted to recruit new followers,
like the previously mentioned Lawrence Gordon
and a junkie named Amanda Young.
Amanda’s second test took place in October
of 2005, when a group of criminals would be
forced to take part in a game at The Nerve
Gas House.
This was the most complex and riskiest game
Jigsaw had ever held, so he enlisted the help
of Hoffman to set it up and test it.
It is here that Hoffman learns never to assume
any outcome.
“I anticipate the possibilities and let
the game play out.”
“Then why do you need Amanda in the game?”
“To ensure that the rules are followed.”
Hoffman seems to think that this method leaves
too much to chance, once again highlighting
his belief that he should be a judge rather
than just an enforcer.
It’s becoming apparent that this is his
biggest flaw, the reason that he’ll never
fully realize the Jigsaw moniker in the future.
John is wary of this, and begins to put a
number of safeguards in place so that Hoffman
isn’t just given free reign in the event
of his passing.
But John does survive the events of the Nerve
Gas House Game in 2005, and goes to work on
his next two games which would take place
simultaneously in April of 2006.
In the meantime, Hoffman still has to keep
up with his actual job as a police detective.
He investigates the classroom trap.... (looks
around)
...the classroom trap, which was created by
another Jigsaw apprentice, Amanda Young.
He has to kind of play dumb at the crime scene,
because he obviously knew that this one wasn’t
created by Jigsaw himself, but he wasn’t
about to make himself look guilty by being
the one to point it out.
Though he could have used reverse psychology
to make himself look less guilty by actively
pointing it out.
But maybe he was using reverse-reverse-psychology,
knowing that the other cops would expect a
guilty person to try using reverse psychology.
But then again…
🤘 Metal Music 🎸
Sorry, that’s literally what my brain is
like… all the time.
In order to keep up the appearance that he’s
actively looking for Jigsaw, he brings in
Jill Tuck, the ex-wife of John Kramer, for
interrogations.
He tries to make her look guilty by asking
why she is in possession of a doll resembling
Billy the Puppet, which is the avatar used
in many of the videotapes Jigsaw left for
his victims.
He also presses her about having the tricycle
that Billy is often seen riding, which she
claims is a relic from John’s youth.
Supposedly there are hours and hours of interrogation
footage.
The next victim to be tested is one of Hoffman’s
fellow investigators, a woman named Alison
Kerry.
Jigsaw wanted to test her because he believed
she was dead on the inside.
Amanda was responsible for setting up this
trap as well, and Hoffman lended her a hand
in hoisting the unconscious body into the
trap.
This would ultimately be a mistake on Hoffman’s
part, one that would lead the FBI to determine
that there were other Jigsaw apprentices besides
Amanda, because she would not have been strong
enough to lift Detective Kerry into the trap
on her own.
Hoffman has to play dumb again at the crime
scene where Kerry is discovered, causing the
two FBI Agents, Peter Strahm and Lindsey Perez
to become somewhat suspicious of him.
Over time, Strahm would become Hoffman's biggest
obstacle.
Hoffman makes some last minute adjustments
on the day that two games would be played
simultaneously on April 28th, 2006.
One involves a man named Jeff Denlon who must
face a series of trials to forgive the people
involved in a drunk driving accident that
killed his son.
Hoffman was responsible for sedating and bringing
in the drunk driver.
John was critical when he saw the way Hoffman
treated the body of the man being tested.
John also offers him some engineering pointers
to better optimize the machine, which is known
as The Rack, that the drunk driver would be
restrained in.
This is an interesting interaction for two
reasons.
Hoffman’s carelessness with the victim shows
us his subconscious desire to do harm.
His goal for taking part in Jigsaw’s operations
is more about punishing wrongdoers than rehabilitating
them.
That’s not something that John Kramer would
approve of.
But the second part of the interaction shows
that Hoffman isn’t just there to assist
Jigsaw with the creation of his traps -- he’s
actively learning about mechanical engineering
because he will be expected to create traps
of his own in the future.
This means that Hoffman is gaining the trust
of Jigsaw, and he may one day be allowed to
take on the Jigsaw name in order to continue
John’s work.
However, Amanda was receiving similar training,
and if Hoffman wanted full control to punish
whoever he pleases, he would have to get her
out of the picture, so the two develop a bit
of a rivalry.
AMANDA: “Get used to me, I’m not going anywhere.”
HOFFMAN: “You sure about that?”
MARIO: "No."
At first, it seems that Hoffman is just taunting
Amanda, but it soon becomes clear that he
has a plan to get rid of her, a plan he was
even able to sneak underneath the nose of
Jigsaw himself.
Outside of Jeff Denlon, there are several
others being tested on April 28th.
One of these is Jeff’s wife, a surgeon named
Lynn Denlon.
Her job is to keep a dying John Kramer alive
as long as possible to make her appreciate
life again.
Amanda is also being tested, because Jigsaw
found out she was letting her emotions interfere
with the natural result of each game by putting
people that she felt should be punished through
inescapable traps, not too different from
what Hoffman did with the Pendulum.
So Amanda's role is to keep Lynn Denlon alive,
so Lynn can keep John Kramer alive.
Amanda doesn’t know she’s being tested,
but Hoffman does, and he comes up with a plan
to use this knowledge to his advantage in
an attempt to get rid of Amanda and Jigsaw
in one fell swoop, leaving him as the last
remaining man in the operation.
With the deaths of Sing, Tapp and Kerry and
with the disappearance of Eric Matthews, Hoffman
was one of the last remaining detectives on
the serial killer task force.
He was there to investigate both traps that
Amanda rigged to be inescapable, so he knew
better than anyone that her weakness was her
fiery emotion, and figured out a way to use
that against her.
While John is on his deathbed, he asks Hoffman
to place a note for Amanda to find, and he
changes it out with a message of his own....
But before she would open it, Hoffman had
some other business to attend to.
He first reports back Jigsaw in secret.
This would be his last face to face with him,
since John didn’t have much longer to live.
John’s last request to Hoffman is to carry
out another game on his behalf after his death.
He hands him an envelope with the instructions,
and Hoffman tucks it away for later.
First, he had another set of tasks to take
care of.
Remember how there was supposed to be a simultaneous
game being played on April 28th?
Well, Hoffman had a lot of work to do to get
that one started.
He has to kidnap Rigg and place him at the
start of his trial, retrieve another cop,
Eric Matthews, and put him on a block of ice,
and presumably also subdue a lawyer named
Art Blank, put him in this neck trap thingy,
and leave him Jigsaw’s instructions on what
to do if he wants to survive.
And then I guess has to kidnap himself, and
go to the room where this is all taking place.
I know that sounds a bit, confusing because…
it is.
But let’s break down how everything is connected.
The main one being tested here is Rigg, because
Jigsaw has determined he’s become too obsessed
with saving his comrades, and isn’t living
his life or spending time with his wife anymore.
There are probably worse people out there
that could be tested, but that's who John
chose, and as long as John is around, Hoffman
has to obey his orders.
In order for Rigg to pass, he simply has to
NOT try to save his co-workers Matthews and
Hoffman.
Matthews is being tested because he’s been
a perpetrator of police brutality.
He already failed Jigsaw’s previous test,
which you can learn about in this video, but
his new test is to see whether or not he’ll
use excessive force to try to escape.
Art Blank is a lawyer being tested for defending
guilty people.
You may remember all those years ago when
Hoffman and Rigg had the run in with the abusive
teacher?
Well, this is the guy who represented him.
Hoffman’s role in all of this is to be the
spectator, and make sure the rules are followed.
Just as John Kramer pretended to be dead in
the original Saw, Amanda pretended to be part
of the game in Saw 2, Hoffman wanted to keep
an eye on this game as well.
DET. KERRY: “Looks like our friend Jigsaw likes to book
himself front row seats to his own sick little games."
It appeared that if Matthews failed to stay
on the ice block, the water would come down
and electrocute Hoffman as well… but, no.
He wasn’t actually in danger because he
had no reason to put himself in danger when
he set up the game.
It was also just to motivate Eric Matthews.
So long story short though, Rigg and Matthews
both fail their tests, so Hoffman is the only
one to walk away alive.
But while that’s all happening, let’s
not forget that that other game is still going
on at the same time.
The one with Lynn Denlon, Jeff Denlon, Amanda
Young and Jigsaw.
Remember how Hoffman left that note for Amanda?
The note that was his ultimate move to eliminate
Amanda and Jigsaw, who were standing in his
way of complete freedom?
Yes, that note?
How about we roll it?
“Dear pesky plumbers.”
Aggh!
Wrong note!
Roll the other note.
“Amanda - You were with Cecil the night
Jill lost Gideon.
You killed their child.
You know it and I know it, so do exactly as
I say.
Kill Lynn Denlon or I will tell John what
you did.”
Hoffman is referring to the night that John
Kramer's unborn child was killed by an addict
named Cecil.
John does not know that Amanda was in on it
too, and Amanda, for obvious reasons, doesn't
really want him to find out.
If you're wondering how Hoffman even knows,
I'm guessing it's because he's a cop and probably
reviewed security footage after the break
in was reported, but they didn't really have
any evidence that Amanda was part of it, and
John never pressed charges on Cecil anyway
so at the end of the day the cops knew, but
John didn't.
So Amanda caves into Hoffman's threat, and
kills Lynn Denlon at the end of the game.
That causes Jeff Denlon to want to kill Amanda,
which he does.
Then, Jeff Denlon, who is still in a rage,
kills Jigsaw for putting him and his family
through all of this.
This is a huge deal for Hoffman.
Remember, the only reason he began helping
Jigsaw in the first place was because Jigsaw
threatened to release the truth about Hoffman
getting revenge on his sister’s killer if
he didn’t comply.
That’s the main reason he helped Jigsaw
from the events of the first Saw in 2004 through
Saw 4 in 2006.
But now, with Jigsaw and Amanda both out of
the picture, Hoffman’s secret was safe.
There was nothing forcing him to continue
Jigsaw’s work anymore.
He could easily go back to being a regular
cop at this point.
But this is the most interesting part of Hoffman’s
character arc.
Some part of him liked being the hand of Jigsaw.
I think it goes back to the reason he got
involved with all of this: his sister Angelina.
Hoffman must have felt in some way, that by
bringing her killer to justice, he was entitled
to judge the fates of any future criminals
in the city.
He had become a cop to protect people, but
found that the police didn’t have enough
power to enforce the law in a way that he
sees fit.
That’s why he started bending the rules.
It started when he signed the affidavit for
Rigg to get the abusive teacher thrown in
jail.
It continued when he murdered the junkie who
threatened Matt Gibson.
And it reached its peak when Hoffman literally
became Jigsaw, who was now a feared symbol
of twisted vigilante justice.
In fact, over the last two years, as Hoffman
got closer and closer to taking Amanda Young
and John Kramer out of the equation, he developed
a condition known as megalomania.
Some of you may be more familiar with the
greek version of the word: megalovania.
🎵 Megalovania - Undertale (parody) 🎵
Today, megalomania is known by mental health
professionals as Narcissistic Personality
Disorder, but we’re still gonna be calling
it megalomania, because it’s way, way more
fun to say.
I think I’m actually gonna say megalomania
as much as possible from now on.
Megalomania is characterized by an intense
obsession with power, and delusions that they
are more important than anyone around them.
Other symptoms include calculative or manipulative
behavior, violent tendencies, egotism, lack
of empathy, entitlement and a God complex.
Cock it and pull it.
With his new power as the sole proprietor
of the Jigsaw legacy, Hoffman planned to run
the city as he saw fit, and punish anyone
who got in his way.
The only issue for him was that he was not
the last Jigsaw disciple left standing.
There was… another.
Shortly after the conclusion of the two simultaneous
games, Special Agent Strahm, who had been
hot on the tail of Officer Rigg for most of
that day, showed up to Gideon Meat Packing
Plant with the hope that he could catch Jigsaw
or whichever disciple was responsible.
When Hoffman realized this, he saw the opportunity
to possibly take him out as well, and quietly
closed the door, locking Strahm in the room
with the corpses of John, Amanda, Lynn Denlon
and Jeff Denlon, before cutting the power.
He then went to retrieve a pig mask to conceal
his identity in case of the possibility of
Strahm surviving.
John has left one more game behind for Agent
Strahm to find, and when he steps through
the secret door, which is his only path forward,
Hoffman takes him out and puts him to sleep.
While Strahm is out, he’s placed inside
the Water Cube trap…
I guess Jigsaw watched too many Panic!
At the Disco music videos on his deathbed
and got a little bit inspired.
Maybe more than a little bit.
Hoffman assumes that Strahm is going to die
in the water cube and goes to rescue the Denlon’s
daughter, Corbett, who was being kept in a
cell as motivation for Jeff to win his game
(which as we know, didn’t work out).
So Hoffman brings her out to police where
he’s lauded as a hero for saving this girl
from Jigsaw, but to his surprise, he and Corbett
are not the only two survivors.
Agent Strahm had punctured his trachea to
survive the Water Cube trap, and was being
brought out to the ambulance.
When Hoffman sees Strahm on a gurney, he knows
that his secret is not safe quite yet, not
as long as Strahm and the FBI continue to
investigate.
He makes up a story for the public about how
he too ended up falling into a Jigsaw trap,
but his arm straps broke and he was able to
escape and find and rescue Corbett.
As the police continue to infiltrate Gideon
Meatpacking Plant, they eventually open the
door and find the bodies of John, Amanda,
Lynn and Jeff, and send them to the morgue
for an autopsy and this is where we have...
an error.
Yeahhh…
I've been able to piece everything together
in a way that kind of makes sense up to this
point, but I can't make any excuses for how
the dates kind of contradict each other here.
Remember how I said the simultaneous games
took place on April 28th?
We know that because the fingerprints that
lead the FBI to Rigg came back on the 28th.
The problem is that the date on John’s autopsy
tag is October 21st, 2006.
See it clearly says it right there.
I’m sure I’m not the first one to notice
this.
What am I doing with my life?
It doesn’t take 6 months to do an autopsy,
and judging by the lack of decomposition on
John’s body…
I can’t show it but feel free to pull up
the movie if you don’t believe me… it
hasn’t been very long.
So that means one of these dates has got to
be wrong, and all we can do is speculate on
which one.
And I think this one is wrong and John’s
death was in April.
Here’s my rationale.
We later see Hoffman looking at evidence bags
containing Strahm’s cell phone and the pen
he used to poke the hole in his neck.
Those give us a month and day when the evidence
was collected, May 7th, and then the day that
evidence was moved to storage, which appears
to be July 7th.
It makes much more sense that they find the
evidence one week after Strahm escaped the
crime scene, as opposed to 7 months after.
So let’s throw this tag out and say that
Jigsaw’s autopsy took place in late April
or early May, and that’s when they found
the hidden tape in his stomach that has a
message for Detective Hoffman.
Roll it.
JIGSAW: “Are you there Detective?
If so, you are probably the last man standing.
Now perhaps you will succeed where the others
have failed.
You think you will walk away untested?
I promise that my work will continue.”
Clever wording by Jigsaw here to hide the
fact that he was working with Hoffman while
still delivering that message, since there
are other people in the room listening to
the tape as well.
In July, the police department holds a ceremony
honoring all of the fallen officers lost throughout
the Saw saga, where Detective Hoffman is promoted
to Detective Lieutenant for his supposed heroics
in putting an end to the Jigsaw murders and
saving Corbett.
When receiving his service award he gives
a speech about how life must be cherished,
and how true justice has been served.
Again, this is also clever wording, because
the audience thinks he’s talking about John
Kramer being brought to justice, when he’s
actually talking about everyone who went through
Kramer’s traps.
And when he says life must be cherished, they
think he’s talking about the lives of the
lost officers, but in reality he’s echoing
Jigsaw’s mantra, “Cherish your life.”
By doing so, we learn one of the reasons that
Hoffman decides to continue operating as Jigsaw.
It seems that he actually does believe in
John's values, he just has different standards
for judging whether or not people should be
punished.
And like I said, and enjoy… continuing to
say because it's a very fun word to say…
this is probably a result of his megalomania.
Megalomania.
Once the fallout of the end of the Jigsaw
case ended, Hoffman got to work on the next
game.
This is the one that John secretly told him
about when he was on his deathbed, and it
involves five people who all played a part
in causing a deadly fire, due to greed and
corruption in their work.
The specific traps and audio tapes were mostly
all created by Jigsaw before his death, so
all Hoffman had to do was start and facilitate
the game, by keeping an eye on it using these
computer monitors.
He believed that this would be the last favor
he has to do for John Kramer.
After that, he should have free reign to find
his own victims.
But he hadn’t quite seized the full power
of Jigsaw just yet.
Someone else was keeping an eye on him, and
they made it known by sending a note reading:
“I know who you are,” the same note that
he received after killing Seth Baxter.
Remember, the first time he got this note,
it was from John himself, so Hoffman can only
speculate on who might be sending this new
note.
The only person Hoffman knows about who had
inside knowledge was Amanda, but she died
that the same time as John.
He knew Agent Strahm was onto him, but Strahm
wouldn't have known about the original note
from 2004.
This new note had the exact same wording.
His best guess is that it’s John's ex-wife
Jill Tuck, but it doesn't make sense for her
either.
They had already seen each other at Gideon
Meat Packing Plant while they were putting
the final touches on the simultaneous games
back in April, so they both already knew about
each other, and Hoffman didn’t have to worry
about her turning him in because she'd just
be putting herself in danger by doing so.
He’s called into the hospital where he finds
Agent Strahm sitting by Perez’s hospital
bed.
This leads him to believe the injuries she
had sustained in one of John’s traps had
done her in.
(She wasn’t really dead, I’m guessing
she was just moved to another room for more
intensive care, but Hoffman didn’t know
that.)
Strahm tells him that the last thing she said
was "Detective Hoffman".
He finds this very suspicious, and… perhaps
unwisely… gives Hoffman an earful about
how strange it is that Jigsaw would make a
mistake by letting Hoffman escape.
HOFFMAN: “Jigsaw’s dead.”
STRAHM: “I’m not talking about him.
I’m talking about you and your whole crooked
department.”
“My department’s gone.
They’re all dead.
There’s no one left.”
STRAHM: “Besides you.”
I feel so bad for Fisk.
Nobody ever remembers Fisk….
Play the sad music.
🎵 sad music 🎵
After making sure he’s not being followed,
Hoffman visits the new underground lair where
he’s monitoring the game, and gets there
just in time to see it begin.
In Hoffman’s new lair, we see a miniature
model of the game that’s taking place, just
like the models that John used to use for
his games.
I think this is an important indicator of
how much Hoffman had learned from John in
their years together.
We previously saw John giving Hoffman pointers
on one of the traps, and now it would appear
that Hoffman had learned everything about
his methods -- meaning that Hoffman could
create his own games if he chose to.
After checking in on the game, Hoffman decides
it’s best to contact Strahm and see if he
can redirect his suspicions somewhere else.
He calls the FBI’s headquarters from an
undisclosed location and asks for Strahm,
but is instead connected to his superior,
Special Agent Erickson.
Hoffman’s strategy is to use Strahm’s
own theory against him.
He tells Erickson that Strahm believes there
was another accomplice outside of Amanda Young,
perhaps someone on the inside.
He just doesn’t mention the part about it
possibly being him.
By doing this, he is secretly planting the
seed of Strahm being a suspect into Erickson’s
head.
It’s a risky move, because that’s sort
of a double edged sword, but it makes sense
considering one of the side effects of megalomania
is cockiness and overconfidence.
Erickson asks to reconnect with him the next
morning to discuss further, but Hoffman has
one more idea to further the notion of Strahm
being a suspect in Erickson’s head.
He drives to where the FBI headquarters is
located and waits for Erickson to come out.
Then, using Strahm’s phone which he recovered
from the evidence bag, he calls Erickson and
promptly hangs up.
Erickson calls back, but he rejects the call
and turns off the device.
Another symptom of megalomania is manipulation
of others.
Hoffman does this to remind Erickson about
the idea he planted in his head earlier, the
idea that Strahm could be the second accomplice.
It works, because Erickson tells his assistant
to start tracking Strahm’s phone.
Now, Hoffman can lead them wherever he pleases
by simply leaving Strahm’s phone somewhere
when he turns it back on.
And that’s exactly what he does.
He goes back to his lair, where the game is
being held, and leaves Strahm’s phone, along
with several photos of Special Agent Erickson
to make it look like Strahm was Jigsaw’s
successor and his boss was the next target.
To top it off, he leaves a hot beverage on
the desk to make it look like Strahm had just
been there recently.
From there, Hoffman went back to the Metropolitan
Police Department where Strahm was waiting
for him in secret.
He again shows what a skilled manipulator
he is, by looking suspicious as he left the
building, thereby getting Strahm to follow
him.
He led Strahm to an empty house where there
was another trap waiting in the basement.
Let’s roll the tape.
HOFFMAN: “Hello Agent Strahm.
If you are hearing this then you have once
again found what you are looking for.
Or so you think…
As the old adage goes, fool me once, shame
on you...
Fool me twice, shame on me.”
He actually reveals how to escape from this
trap, but Strahm doesn’t trust him at all,
and thus, doesn’t believe him.
When Hoffman goes into the room, Strahm attacks
him and forces him into the box, not realizing
that Hoffman had been telling the truth, and
the box was actually the only way to escape
the room.
The walls close in Star Wars garbage compactor
style and crush Agent Strahm.
This is an excellent example of how Hoffman
had taken the teachings of Jigsaw and twisted
them for his own benefit.
His goal all along was to get rid of Strahm,
but he was unsuccessful in his first attempt.
So the second time, he uses Jigsaw’s teachings,
specifically, his teachings about how to anticipate
the human mind to his advantage.
“If you’re good at anticipating the human
mind, it leaves nothing to chance.”
After getting out of the glass box, Hoffman
recovers Strahm’s hand and uses it to plant
fingerprints all over the crime scenes of
previous victims.
Part of the genius of making everyone think
that Strahm was the second accomplice to Jigsaw
was that Hoffman could continue to run new
traps and games, because everyone was out
looking for Strahm and not him.
The next trap that Hoffman would put into
action, however, would be another one designed
by John Kramer.
He had left instructions in his will for Jill
Tuck to carry out even more new traps.
She most likely contacted Hoffman to get his
help with a few of them, because she’d never
actually been involved in John’s operation
and didn’t have the experience.
His next victims were a pair of malicious
lenders who repossess the valuables of desperate
people in need.
This was another game that was planned by
John, based on the fact that it’s his voice
on the tape, but was never carried out before
his death.
So Hoffman got to do it instead.
The victims must see how it feels to give
up what is vital to them by sacrificing their
own flesh into a scale in order to survive.
After the conclusion of the test, Hoffman
does something interesting that Jigsaw had
not.
It seems he was recording audio of the victims
trying to escape rather than staying behind
and witnessing it himself.
He plays it back after the fact, either to
try to learn from the experience and improve
his anticipation skills, or possibly just
for his own sick pleasure as he was starting
to enjoy torturing people.
After setting the trap, he’s called into
investigate it due to his unique position
as Lieutenant Detective.
There, he finds the FBI has taken over the
investigation and that they had discovered
the Strahm fingerprints that he’d planted
there.
He also discovers that Special Agent Perez,
who he previously thought to be deceased,
was alive, well and working on this investigation.
Erickson had led Hoffman to believe she was
dead earlier that month, because they actually
had suspected Hoffman and wanted to have an
extra piece to play against him if need be.
But now that Strahm was their #1 target, the
FBI offers to work with Hoffman.
This is where Hoffman’s sociopathy really
shines more than ever before.
He’s basically toying with the FBI at this
point.
He feigns disinterest in working with them
because of their dishonesty about the fate
of Ms. Perez, and this ultimately causes Erickson
to offer him full disclosure on all future
secrets -- a deal that he accepts.
“From now on, everything we know, you know.
Is that fair?”
The brilliant part is, he’s basically guaranteed
his own safety because he’s now working
with both parties who are investigating Jigsaw:
The Metropolitan Police Department and the FBI.
However, these two may have been the only
ones making a formal investigation, but there
would be others in search of the truth.
One day Hoffman goes to visit the survivor
of the flesh trap at the hospital, and on
the way he runs into Pamela Jenkins, a journalist
that he accuses of twisting the facts to get
a good story.
Or as I like to call it, a journalist.
Jenkins promises to dial down her articles
if Mark can connect her with Jill Tuck, so
he agrees to help her out.
My guess is that he did so because he felt
he would have even more power if he had the
media on his side too.
From there, he goes to visit the other victim
of the flesh trap, the one who didn’t make it.
The autopsy reveals a different knife was
used to cut the Jigsaw piece compared to all
the other victims besides one, and that one
is Seth Baxter, the man who killed Hoffman’s sister.
The FBI wants to find the Seth Baxter tape,
and if Strahm’s voice is on it, that will
be all the evidence they need to publicly
convict him.
But I think they also secretly did still suspect
Hoffman a little bit, because he obviously
did have the motive.
That night, he goes to visit Jill Tuck at
her work, and demands she give up the contents
of the box left to her in John’s will.
This is just a prime example of Hoffman’s
megalomania.
He is so desperate to control everything and
everyone that he’s going to go against John’s
dying wishes and usurp power from one of the
few people that knows about him so that he
can control all aspects of the game.
He makes her hand over the files of the victims
who are to be tested next, a group of people
who all work for, or are connected to this
dirty insurance company called Umbrella Health.
Meanwhile, Erickson and Perez are continuing
the re-investigation of the Seth Baxter case,
and ask Hoffman to come in to see their findings.
They’re able to uncover the master tape
left behind at the pendulum trap, but it’s
been intentionally distorted, so they send
it to a lab to be descrambled.
This makes Hoffman nervous because he knows
that’s his voice on the tape, and they will
eventually uncover it but he has no choice
but to travel with them to the lab.
SP. AGENT ERICKSON: “Come on, you’re coming right?”
“Of course.”
It can be assumed that they go through some
kind of security checkpoint before entering
the FBI facility to separate Hoffman from
his gun.
Like I said, they were secretly a bit suspicious
of him still.
The scene at the lab where the audio is defiltered
is perhaps my favorite scene in the Saw franchise.
As the technician gets closer and closer to
uncovering Hoffman’s real voice, the tension
in the room builds.
SP. AGENT PEREZ: “You OK?”
HOFFMAN: “Huh?”
“You seem a little preoccupied.”
“Oh, I’m just anxious about the tape.”
The pressure in Hoffman’s chest continues
to rise when Perez expresses her doubt that
Strahm is really responsible, based on his
past behaviour as her partner.
She’s basically making it clear to Hoffman
that she never believed he was innocent.
And you can just see Hoffman struggling to
keep his cool as his big lie slowly unfolds
in front of these FBI agents.
He’s quickly trying to throw together a
plan in his head, using only a few items from
a snack table to prepare for the moment when
he’s exposed.
But the big bomb is the moment when Erickson
drops another discovery.
Roll.
That.
Clip.
SP AGENT ERICKSON: “In other words, when he left his fingerprints
on the latest victims, Strahm was already
dead!”
TAPE: “Right now you’re feeling helpless.”
LAB TECH: “There it is!”
After two years of quietly helping Jigsaw,
and after months of effort diverting the Metropolitan
Police Department and the FBI, Mark Hoffman
was finally backed into a corner, but he wasn’t
about to go down without a fight.
He slashes Erickson with a pastry knife and
burns Perez with a piping hot coffee.
He uses the lab technician as a meat shield,
protecting himself from Perez’s gunshots
long enough to get to her and take her out
as well.
Before finishing her off, he asks who else
knows about him, to which she replies…
“EVERYONE.”
"Everyone?"
"EVERYONE!!!"
With that, he retrieves a can of gasolene
from his car and comes back to burn the whole
******** place to the ground.
One of the most brutal details in this scene
highlights how much of a psychopath Hoffman
had become.
When he returns to the lab, he notices Erickson
still alive, and rather than put him out of
his suffering before starting the fire, he
chooses the most painful punishment imaginable
and covers him in even more gasolene before
lighting a flame and tossing the match.
With his pursuers now taken care of, he returns
to the zoo, the site of the game that was
currently taking place, just in time to see
the end of it.
But when he gets there, he finds a relic from
his past, which fills him with even more uncertainty.
It’s the same note he left for Amanda three
months ago, threatening her to kill Lynn Denlon.
He realizes it’s nearly impossible for anyone
to know about this, and knows he’s still
in trouble when he sees it.
When he sits down in his chair, he’s jolted
by a powerful wave of electricity.
Whoever had been there had booby-trapped the
seat.
When he comes to, he discovers who was responsible:
Jill Tuck.
She had hidden one thing left for her in her
ex-husband’s will: the fact that Mark Hoffman
was also meant to endure one more test.
Hoffman knew this after hearing the tape found
in Kramer’s stomach at the autopsy, but
after three months he thought he was in the
clear.
Jill subjects him to a classic Jigsaw device,
the reverse bear trap, and leaves him in the
room to die.
Jill’s instructions were to leave Hoffman
restrained in the reverse bear trap as punishment
for deviating from Jigsaw’s plan.
Hoffman was supposed to die there.
The only problem was that Jill Tuck was no
Jigsaw.
She had not thought out every possible scenario
the way John might have, and Hoffman is able
to exploit this by breaking his hand with
the machine fastened to his face, using it
to untie himself from the chair and lodging
the reverse bear trap into the steel bars
covering the window on the door.
This prevents it from tearing his face open
when time expires, and gives him just enough
time to escape from it’s confines.
His jaw is damaged in the incident, but he
does survive, and swears to have his revenge
on Jill.
Aftering taping up his injured hand, he takes
the reverse bear trap with him and retreats
to a new safehouse at an abandoned air hangar.
He fixes himself up.
Realizing that Jill got away and will probably
go to the police, he knows he’ll never be
able to go back to his old life and destroys
his cell phone and ID cards.
He also decides to lie low for a while, and
goes into hiding for the next 8 months, not
emerging again until March of 2007.
During the time in hiding, he used his inside
knowledge of the police headquarters to hack
into the station’s security system and spy
on them.
With him out, and most of his department dead,
the police chief brings back an old face to
take over the Jigsaw investigation:
🎵 EPIC MUSIC 🎵
sorry Fisk… he went with Officer Matt Gibson.
🎵 sad music 🎵
FISK: "Jeez."
By the way, remember way, way back about a half hour ago when I told you he might come back?
“Gibson transferred to Internal Affairs,
where he busted three of Hoffman’s men,
and Hoffman swore he’d have his revenge.
Just remember that, because it could come
back.
I’m not saying it’s gonna come back.
But it might come back.”
Ahh yes, good memories of when I was a younger
creator.
So Hoffman kept his eye on whatever was going
on at the police station.
He also had information on three more groups
that Jigsaw never had time to test.
So his next objective is to carry these out.
First, he captures three participants of a
toxic love triangle and puts them through
a unique trap that takes place in public.
The two men have to execute their former lover
to survive.
Next, four racists are trapped in an elaborate
setup at Pete’s Auto Body Shop and there
are no survivors.
He leaves a note for Gibson on the bathroom
mirror, along with the reverse bear trap which
is covered in Jill Tuck’s fingerprints.
As if that’s a reliable measure of anything
at this point, considering all we’ve been
through.
And finally, the last game of the Jigsaw saga
is held on March 12th and tests a man named
Bobby Dagen, who had falsely claimed to be
a survivor of a Jigsaw trap in order to sell
his book.
Hopefully I’m not the only one who appreciates
the irony of Hoffman, who once pretended to
be Jigsaw for personal gain, now setting up
a real trap for Bobby, who had pretended to
be a victim for personal gain.
With the last of these traps set into motion,
Hoffman could focus all of his efforts on
what now mattered most to him, getting revenge
on Jill Tuck and Matt Gibson.
He starts by sending a DVD to Gibson’s safehouse,
in which he openly shows his face and requests
that Gibson hands over Jill Tuck.
If he complies, Hoffman says he will stop
the last game, and the killing will end.
But Gibson has promised immunity to Jill and
isn’t about to trust a bargain made by a
serial killer.
Hoffman’s next communication with Gibson
is an email with a video message, giving him
a cryptic clue, that he must look beyond the
crossroad to the clear dawn.
Look beyond the crossroad is a reference to
Crossroads Manufacturing, which is the abandoned
factory turned flophouse where Hoffman saved
Gibson’s life all those years ago, and clear
dawn is a reference to Clear Dawn Psychiatric
Hospital, where the man who nearly killed
Gibson used to be a patient.
That’s where the Bobby Dagen game is being
held, but Hoffman goes back to Pete’s Auto
Body, which is where the Car Trap was located
and remotely detonates a bomb nearby in order
to lure all of the cops, who were still collecting
evidence, outside for a little while.
Hoffman uses this time to go into a hidden
room inside the auto body shop and check on
the video feed of the game using the monitors.
Then he sets up a trap for Gibson and his
men, who would soon be on their way after
they trace his email back to this room.
And this is the moment that all of the training
with Jigsaw finally pays off for Hoffman.
He had studied under John Kramer to learn
the ways of a great mechanical engineer, he
had practiced for nearly 3 years by tweaking
and carrying out John’s traps and he had
obtained the experience needed to fully create
a trap of his own.
He disregarded John’s code of conduct though
-- this trap’s intention was not to rehabilitate,
but rather, to kill.
He removed the body of one of the victims
of the Car Trap and placed him in the room
wearing Jigsaw’s cloak, so that Gibson would
be lured into the trap and executed by the
motion activated turret hidden in the corner
of the room.
We know that Hoffman had long desired his
revenge on Gibson,
but the fact that he wasn’t
even there for his death shows where Mark’s
priorities were at the time.
He was still mad about Jill Tuck trying to
kill him off in the reverse bear trap and
then selling him out to the cops, and his
one burning desire at that point was to get
to her and have his revenge.
He hid himself in the now empty body bag of
the fourth victim, which was a clever way
of sneaking himself into the police station.
Once there, he went on a huge killing spree.
It started with the coroner.
This was the man whose discovery about the
knife that cut each Jigsaw piece led the FBI
to reopen their investigation about Seth Baxter,
which ultimately led to Hoffman getting caught.
Now I may need Dead Meat to back me up on
this, I’m the History expert, not the Math
expert, but according to my calculations,
I believe he kills five more people at the
police station on his way to the holding cell
where Jill is being kept.
When he gets into the cell, he forcefully
grabs her by the hair and asks, “how do
I look,” which seems like a weird thing
to say at first…
I mean they’re not going on a date, they’re
basically trying to kill each other, which
is usually more of a 3rd date activity for
me, but I think the line is a reference to
the fact that this is the first time they’ve
seen each other since Jill put the reverse
bear trap on him, which messed up his jaw
and permanently changed his appearance.
She stabs him in the neck with a nail file
and scampers away, where she hides in the
evidence room.
But Hoffman, who was again able to use his
Jigsaw powers to anticipate her actions, goes
in after her, but Jill Tuck would not be the
only thing found there.
After discovering Jill’s hiding place, Hoffman
realized exactly where he was.
He was in the evidence room, meaning that
he would have access to the very same tool
that Jill had tried to kill him with 8 months
ago, the reverse bear trap.
This is actually the version of the Bear Trap that Jigsaw had
used to test Amanda way back when she was being tested.
He finds it most fitting to leave Jill behind
in the same position on the same chair she
had shocked him with the previous summer,
but unlike Hoffman, Jill does not have what
it takes to escape, and she is killed.
After the trap ends her life, Hoffman closes
with Jigsaw’s iconic phrase…
“Game over.”
Even a small change like this, saying Game
Over after the victim’s death as opposed
to before, is indicative of how Hoffman’s
version of Jigsaw refused to play by the rules
the way that Kramer’s version of Jigsaw
did.
Hoffman has his own dirty way of doing things,
that is inspired by Jigsaw, but not limited
by a code of conduct.
Having gotten his revenge, he retires to his
secret safehouse in the hangar where he prepares
a bag full of money and supplies.
He’s probably planning to go into hiding
again for a while, since he just took out
an entire police station which is likely to
draw more federal attention.
Wanting to clear out everything and start
somewhere new, he lights up the hangar and
on his way out, but before he can make it
very far he’s captured, by three men in
pig masks.
Throughout the course of this saga, Hoffman
had brilliantly accounted for everything his
opposition would throw at him, but there was
still one thing he was not able to solve:
who had sent him the note: “I know who you
are.”
The answer would take Hoffman back to 2004,
where one of his first tasks under John Kramer
was to plant a doctor’s penlight at one
of his crime scenes, and that doctor was named
Lawrence Gordon.
Unbeknownst to Hoffman, Gordon had become
a secret apprentice to Jigsaw after surviving
the bathroom game in 2004 and was working
behind the scenes for John ever since.
He kept an eye on Hoffman after John’s death
and was instructed to act immediately if anything
were to happen to Jill.
According to John’s orders, Gordon was to
take Hoffman to the same bathroom where he
had once been tested, and leave him with no
escape.
Hoffman desperately reaches for the hacksaw,
knowing that his best chance to escape was
to sever his own foot, but Gordon takes it
and throws it out of reach.
“Game over.”
Notice how he does it correctly, by saying
it before the victim’s death.
Just saying.
So we’re here, we’re almost at the end
of this very long video, but we’ve actually
hit a bit of a point of contention among Saw
fans, because that’s the last we see of
Hoffman, and there’s a bit of divide over
his ultimate fate.
Did he die in the bathroom?
Or would he have found some way to escape?
There are even conflicting reports from the
creators of the film.
In an audio commentary on Saw 7, they mention
that Hoffman is dead, but according to the
actor that played him, Costas Mandylor, or
as I like to call him, The Mandylorian, Hoffman
is still alive.
So with that all being said, I have the answer.
Hoffman’s dead.
And here’s why.
Outside of the fact that it would totally
undo Saws 4-7 and make them essentially pointless,
let’s look at the canon for our answer.
We don’t see anything that happened after
Hoffman was left in the bathroom until the
next sequel, Jigsaw, came out in 2017.
In Jigsaw, the killings begin again after
10 years of inactivity, and another investigation
opens up.
Nobody, at any point, mentions Hoffman as
a possible suspect, and this is most likely
because they eventually discovered the bathroom
and found him dead in there.
And yes, we do know that they discovered the
bathroom because Eleanor has a replica of
the hacksaws, and these weren’t something
that could be found in any other location.
So that’s why I think Hoffman is almost
definitely dead, and I say almost because
it could be that he escaped and he’s in
jail somewhere, but if that was the case,
you’d think the new investigators in Jigsaw
would at least double check that he hadn’t
escaped or something.
And on top of that, the end of his story is
just a more fitting way to go out.
But until we see his grave or some kind of
confirmation in a future sequel, I know that
you Hoffman fans aren’t ever gonna shut
up, so I’ll just leave at that for now.
Let me know your opinion on that in the comments
though and if you want to see some more of
your favorite Saw characters on Horror History
then click that playlist on the left.
And if you love horror, if you love Saw, there’s
gonna be more content on the way soon.
We’re getting close to a new Saw movie coming
out so make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, RING that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Megalomania, megalomania, megalomania, assuming
we both survive.